I don't hear social media I hear Tik Tok
and then I double click Tik Tok regular
post Tik Tock live different I don't
hear LinkedIn not just where you put
your resume no no I hear that's a social
network double click there's regular
posts there's video there's written word
there's pictures this is science
attention is the number one asset Gary
what is a brand what is a brand what is
a brand it's reputation it's what people
think it's what people feel when they
hear something and obviously that we
think about that from a Clos standpoint
but it's about I just told you right
before we popped off Madison Square
Garden the Knicks versus America those
were two Brands I debated to where to
put my office he rocks in with a
Philadelphia hat I literally felt
something right away because I've always
felt like Philly was actually more New
York than New York especially as this
Island's gotten real Rich so brand is
what people on the other side feel about
something it's reputation on a personal
level and on a product it's is this
something I want to be associated with
cuz I like it or I feel a certain way
about it when you was building your
brand who was was the team players who
who how did you pick your team at the
people that you need how did you build
your infrastructure to build the brand
that you was that it became today from
the ground level this isn't that's oh I
like this question so it's funny where
my brain went the first thing that
mattered to me is that I had no team for
as long as humanly
possible I think you know we got well
let me phrase I got lucky because the
world of building a brand on the
internet happened when I was grown I was
30 years old before I ever made a video
in my life MH these kids don't have that
opportunity all every 13-year-old is now
thinking about that day one every human
that is under 20 years old right now is
actively being a human and being the pr
person of themselves they live in a
different world than we grew up in so
for me I got lucky and I don't like
throwing around that word because that's
what losing players try to throw at
winners so I I use luck I use luck very
carefully but I did get fortunate lucky
that all this popped off off when I
really knew who I was you know and
things really didn't start happening to
me until like 35 38 39 I was grown and
when I started realizing something was
happening first I did wine videos then I
did business what was most important to
me is I wanted to be in the dirt on
everything I didn't want to start hiring
people doing [__] I didn't know how to
do cuz I knew that I wouldn't know how
to judge them if I hadn't done it mhm
and I learned that in my dad's liquor
store the reason I was a killer and
built a huge business was I made ice
I stock shelves I work the register
there was not one thing that anybody
that worked for me was doing that I
hadn't done and so when I was building
my brand when I realized wait a minute
something's happening this Gary B thing
can pop off before I get everybody else
to like come and team up with me I want
to understand first me what the [__] do
I give a [__] about cuz just I want to
be famous and make money is not like
that's something that you do but it's
not who you are and first I want to
understand like why is this all
happening so a lot of why talk and then
the way I started building my team was
hiring people to do [__] that I wasn't
good at or I didn't want to do first
person I ever had to join me in my life
was an admin administrator that's right
cuz I had no [__] clue how to manage
my time like I was trying to I was
saying yes to everything and then like
nine people would show up at the same
place be like I have a meeting with you
like [__] you know cuz I didn't write
[__] down it was all in the dome and I
was good at it until it got so big
literally no [__] three people would
show up at cuz I was building my brand
at my dad's liquor store and then kind
of starting to come over in New York
Jersey New York doing my thing literally
one day three people showed up on the
same day and they're like yo I've got a
meeting yo I got a meeting yo I got a
meeting and I remember I'm like I'm
losing cuz it cuz I I'm very
compassionate and empathetic and I what
I was most upset about is like I don't
want these people to feel like I'm big
timing them it's why I hate being late
especially back then I was just on the
come up especially now where I got a
little little something I know what
people are thinking that I think my time
is more valuable than theirs so my
biggest anxiety is being like 2 minutes
late to a zoom or something cuz I hate
that feeling anyway regardless first
admin cuz I had to organize my
[__] and then then I just needed someone
to like help me Andy K who's doing my
vriends thing with me right now came in
as an intern and was to help me with my
book jab jab jab right hook and I saw he
had a little something and I was like
wait a minute maybe I could do something
and I was like you know what going to
make more content I started putting a
little team together Andy then drock
came India Steve Unwin Zach Moy Tyler
like it just started happening and so
early early on it was somebody filming
whatever I was doing like Dustin's doing
now at the time it was a show like the
ask scary V show like I'll do a show on
YouTube and put it out and you guys and
gals need to put it on YouTube record it
and put on YouTube and record it and put
on a podcast and then it started
building and then Instagram got more
important we started thinking about the
how to be great at Instagram how to be
great at it all I was always doing me on
Twitter I was always doing the tweeting
I was always replying cuz I wanted to be
in the trenches in the dirt and so after
admin it became people to scale what I
wanted to put in the world the
production team behind me living my life
which then cultivated in them literally
following me 24/7 and filming me I did
daily V for 5 years that really took me
to a different place and so we keep
building I keep thinking about what am I
not good at what don't I like when you
start making paper and you can start
deploying it cuz the first seven eight
years of Wine Library TV in my brand I
didn't have the money to build a team
yeah so I had of I had I could be I'm
all strategist I want to do everything
and seem like it was also I couldn't
afford it I couldn't yeah I had once you
start affording it everyone where you
got a little bit of pay the biggest
mistake people that start to pop off get
a brand deal is they want the
money to buy like a this yeah and a this
what they should be doing is taking that
money early on and hiring the people to
help them do
what they do great and to scale them the
kid that makes 200,000 which is a ton of
money year one when they popped whatever
it is ads from Tik Tok and YouTube or a
brand deal or what speaking or whatever
it is that kid that goes from zero to
200k he or she don't forget it's 100K
after taxes or 130 whatever it is he or
she always levels up lifestyle before
they level up organization mhm that kid
needs to realize no no no at that 130
let me get a 40K employee cuz that 130
can be 390 next year but what they do is
they buy
[__] they buy [__] MH and I don't listen
especially knowing your story I grew up
in very humble surroundings I know all
those kids I was in that I get when you
never had it y the [__] thirst for it
I get it my thing is you can have more
of it if you can hold your
breath 12 more months 12 I love you for
that another 12 mons dble up another 12
months triple up like there's like I
said something once in one talk I've
never repeated it but I'm going to
repeat it there was some sort of thing
and they're like kid was like I want a
Porsche I'm like I'm like and it was
talented I was like bro you could buy
the whole Porsche
company but the quickest way that that
won't happen is you focusing on buying
just one Porsche right now mhm people
take chips off the table too soon while
that's major and the Reas and by the way
then that gets me into the real major
[__] why cuz they want to flex on
someone flexing is everything cuz they
cuz that girl hurt their you broke up
with him and so now he's going to show
he's paid and she [__] up yeah right
because his teacher said he was going to
be a garbage man and he's like yo [__]
you Mrs Thompson because his daddy said
you ain't never going to mount to
nothing just like me and he's like nah
dad [__] you look at my Beamer I get it
it's real but it doesn't make it
right and this is why I love the the
world we live in us two we didn't have
platforms 30 years ago [__] you ain't no
producers or Hollywood or the
establishment putting us on to have a
million people watch but now us too
because of our we earned our audience
and the internet is
democratized over the next however
amount of time millions of people over
the next decade will watch this video
and one kid is going to hear one thing
out of our mouths knowing us and she or
he's going to be like
bet change that's why Church mattered
that's why parenting mattered that's why
scripture mattered like it's all
communication and I continue to be
compelled to do [__] like this for one
[__] person on the other side of
these cameras to be like actually that's
right [__] it that's what I'm doing and
then getting the emails and the DMS or
in the street and saying thank you I
live for that [__] I love that [__] and
I'm happy to be with you because you do
that [__] as well which is why I don't
know I don't know if I've ever answered
a text faster than the other day when
you hit me I walked out of a board
meeting I walked out of the [__] Port
I'm like yo and he's like can we chop it
up I'm like cool you podcast I'm like
100% so thank you for having me now
what's the importance of diversifying
your
content I love you for that clearly
maybe you've been you know I've been a
little bit loud about this last 60 days
I'm writing a new book next year it's
going to be called day trading attention
so I've been in it trying to teach
everybody how to win on every platform
Tik Tok YouTube cuz social media is the
current place where attention is if the
metaverse comes I'll be telling you what
to do in those [__] head I don't care
where attention is cable TV 20 years ago
I'd be writing books like cable TV 40
years ago regular TV regular TV 80 years
ago radio how to hack radio I just want
to know where the attention is Spotify
rap cabier is important today it used to
be called TRL it used to be called The
Source it used to like I don't hot 9 I
don't give a [__] I'm agnostic to what
platform has the attention I just want
to figure out where it is I want to be
great at it I don't hear social media I
hear Tik Tock and then I double click
Tik Tock regular post Tik Tock live
different I don't hear LinkedIn not just
where you put your resume no no I hear
that's a social network double click
there's regular posts there's video
there's written word there's pictures
this is science it's skill so
diversifying content is the number one
reason that the person on the other side
of this video right now is not popping
off like she he wants to people get
stuck in ruts they got something that
worked for them or they're comfortable
with and they're posting the same [__]
they posted 5 years ago on Instagram
even though a ton of people are now on
Tik Tok and Instagram so there's less
it's different mhm and we've already
seen all that [__] from you and they get
tired we all grew up with [__] that was
hot as [__] and then three years later
was less hot because we got it that's
why Madonna was a beast she was like oh
I got you for four years now I'm going
to I'm A Material Girl now let me go on
a cross and D I'm going to do this and
I'm going to be Vogue and she just kept
mixing it the [__] upix we understand
and by the way we see that all the time
like there's the people that have one
pitch and they're hot for three years
and we never heard about them again
right and then there's people that are
[__] icons why because they
Diversified their
content that's major now
content I always said to myself do I got
content or I'm just documenting my
journey cuz I'm going let this [__] ever
you recorded or not so what's the
difference between content and
documenting the journey yeah there was a
moment there was a kid in here it was a
big moment for me it exploded for me we
were just chopping and I just cuz thank
God I was filming back there and I just
said he's like I don't know what to make
I said document don't create right
people have shoot days I'm an influencer
I'm on today I'm going to make stuff
that's commercials that's TV that's fine
by the way that works for a lot of
people people like you and me and a lot
of people out there we should be D
documenting mhm not creating right we
because what we do is just who we are it
just you know the best [__] you ever
said the best [__] I ever said it's lost
I said some [__] to my sister the other
day like [__] I wish that [__]
was fil you know like like it's so the
difference
is not a lot the key for everyone is to
be self-aware of who they are some
people this is what blew me away maybe
this hit you too as my life started
changing I started rubbing elbows with
different kind of people I'm like yo
some of these Comedians and actors like
suck in real
life but in the context of doing it for
film they're beast and then you then I
did enough TV and different [__] I'm
like oh this shit's slow you go do a
movie you're like all right back in the
trailer for 3 hours I'm like [__] this
[__] you know for other people we like
it raw clean authentic no [__] no
[__] with it like that works for us so
for everybody on the other side there's
two groups there's the people that
should do it the actors way like they
should make the studio proper they need
their not they need they need to
memorize their lines and then there's us
more improv we're more SNL than we are
feature film right improv live life on
stage you know in the kitchen around a
dinner table chopping stoop life it's
that [__] and so cool like neither's
better the key is does everyone on the
other side of this know who they are and
are they trying to force it one of the
things that was crazy and this will make
sense to you when we grew up being a
rapper an athlete was
like we didn't grow up where the
entrepreneur was there was no me 30
years ago it's crazy to me that kids
look up to me cuz I didn't grow up
having that when I saw when I saw
business people when I was coming up
like new like successful business people
the face of that was Bill Gates the
nerdiest dude I'd ever seen in my life I
didn't want to be that right you know
and so like you know what what's just so
crazy is [__] es and flows so for me the
reason I tell people be self-aware
figure out who you are the world might
come to you I lived in an era where all
my friends parents told all my friends
to stop playing video games it's a waste
of time if one of those parents said go
all in my homie might have been the Tony
Hawk of video games do you understand
that if somebody in the ' 80s or '90s
had a parent that said go all in this is
it go all in and they just went all in
and when I say all in get great at it
but also be get loud about it try to be
on TV try to be in newspapers they would
have been the Tony Hawk of video games
and they'd be getting paid unlimited
amount of money but their parents wanted
them to be a doctor to get paid 200,000
a year what's crazy is my
cousin Jamal he had gave me his GT
Performer right I'm looking at rad you
remember rad I'm riding around and I'm
I'm doing all these trips [__] myself
up trying to do [__] that I don't know
nothing about but I'm like damn and for
those who don't know a GT Performer was
like he listen you this was the bike of
all bikes it was like what Tre is a GT
Performer was on another level go Google
that this was I'm talking about I had
the the trick it had everything on it
this was the bike of the bikes so I got
that he gave it to me he was like here
man I don't want I said so I'm R I'm
looking at Red my my homie S at the time
he had one so we riding we doing all
this but it was like nobody encouraged
it that was like that was
that was like have fun don't take this
serious you're not going to be Tony Hawk
you're not going to be uh you know all
these Rob D you're not going to be none
of we didn't have that we didn't have
the extreme sports and then you look up
years ago I look up I'm sitting in the
cell I'm looking on Cribs hold up Rob
dck this is his [__] house he got a
dirt pike in the back he got you looking
at you remember they had all the extreme
sports guys on [__] cribs and I'm
like he own a mountain in Arizona from
riding a bike riding a dirt bike we
never knew this [__] was gonna happen
you know that the 1982 NBA Finals the
1982 NBA Finals Lakers Sixers mhm did
not air one of the games I think game
six did not air in real time on
television cuz that's where the NBA was
it was on tape
delay damn now the 10th Man on an NBA
team just 40 years later is getting paid
40 million a year because there's that
much money in the NBA and there's only
15 players so it's not like baseball and
football like literally if you're the
ninth man on the Timberwolves in six
years you're rich as F I'm talking
40 you see some of the deals dudes I'm
like I follow basketball and you see
five years 140 you're like who is that
dude again who is he I've never seen him
so like so nobody vot his jersey by the
way 1957 if you're a pilot you're famous
as [__] an astronaut in 1970 you're
[__] as you're [__] Kim Kardashian
and The Rock and Kevin Hart in one [__]
changes now now you walk right by the p
is be you be in the airport they be
walking by nobody pay him attention they
got their white shirts on they walking
by this a dude that got your life in his
hands I got another one kyl used to be
here cook used to be the help of the
help of the help the chef is on the now
the chef is famous as [__] and nobody
pilot we hate them we're like where were
you cuz they right like soon as they
come across the speak oh man what the PE
[__] CH and this is why why are we
talking about this for the last five
minutes I have no idea what the [__]
you're into as you watch this you might
collect stamps cuz your great granddaddy
did and nobody has for the last 20 years
but you might be that person that gets
us all onto stamps right you might like
like [__] changes [__] you might be from
the Caribbean and your style of food is
not popping here well guess what nobody
knew what the [__] Taco Bell was 40
years ago in America easier and if you
go way back pizza and French like people
like pizza was like yo those are the
foreigners trying to put us on to pizza
now it's the like and by the way Mexican
food is like like and Mexican food and
Sushi Japanese food was
nonexistent runs it so what I'm saying
is you can die on someone else's thesis
or you can die on your own and with the
internet and tick you're one Tik Tock
away I saw some dude cuz I'm doing
looking at something who makes animals
out of cotton candy
like he's a cotton candy artist like you
know he's killing it 2.5 million
followers 50 million views and I'm just
like this dude was making 500,000 a year
on a couple cotton candy brand deals and
a couple of cotton candy dude hoodies
and he does cotton candy animals cotton
candy 30 years ago that dude is getting
paid $17 an hour at a carnival yep
shit's changing don't miss your shot
whatever you're about be about that go
hard at it for as long as you can and
then if you gave it a 7 10 year try and
it didn't work out then you can get a
regular job then you can fold it in but
like people give up too soon and they're
embarrassed of their interests that's
probably the best thing that happened in
hip-hop culture in the last 20 years
when we were coming up if you didn't
have timos and a starter jacket you
you'd have an auntie in the hood and
claim you were from there cuz you
visited her once if you lived in a
middle class neighborhood cuz everything
was hard hard hard right people used you
this people made up where they were from
yeah people still do that [__] though
right remember like people were like yo
I'm from crenchaw I'm like no no your
aunt lives in kensaw you visit her for a
week in the summer you live in a solid
solid suburbian town in LA but when you
came to college then you had to show
that you were hard that like it's crazy
now and it started to happen with like I
remember when Bentley with the [__]
umbrellas and I was like something's
happening right right and then you I
mean yachty and Tyler the Creator those
dudes couldn't win in '94 like you had
to be one way one way one way now and so
now it's wide open it's wide open you
can do [__] thank God thank God shit's
people are always focused on what's
worse shit's better go talk to your
grandparents ask them if shit's Better
or Worse man it's way better man I you
know I I remember we didn't have no
remote controls you had to turn the TV
you had to turn that [__] you only had
like three channels you didn't like
everything is right now is like when I
got out of prison I was
like it's a miracle it was
like it was game time because because to
be a to walk around with a satellite in
your pocket first of all listen listen
you got a superc computer in your pocket
you can travel the world with this you
can do everything you attach a debit
card to this you can buy anything you go
anywhere you get any information I can
me and you can sit here right here today
and say you know what that's start a
company called what look around just go
have people looking around on the way go
go daddy look around get somebody yo set
the side up real quick get a landing
page look and just have people looking
around czy [__] now it's $0 Z even that
cost $9 like again we got fortunate we
came from such humble beginnings like I
remember like in college because I had a
$100 bill and we could buy a video game
I was like [__] Bill Gates yeah with
a hundo now how much is this [__] 7even
six five how much is this 11 11,100 no
12 that's 15500 regardless people are
like I'm poor I'm like you have a $1,000
phone yeah you bought $7 coffee [__] got
crazy MH people got confused
yeah people don't realize the power of
Simplicity and humility and not needing
[__] every like I just wish people would
spend more time with 80 90y old people I
think people have got life a little
confused right now they're they're so
focused on what they don't have they
don't have the capacity for the
Gratitude of what they do have starting
with health because regardless I know
unlimited people with 10 figures 20
figures 10 let me do it right seven
figures a million eight figures nine
figures in their bank account and
they've got 18 months to live and
they're not happy MH that hundo million
ain't doing [__] for you if you're
[__] wrapping it up because you're
terminally sick so every day you wake up
and you and the people you love are good
you're good and what G you don't get it
I get fomo why cuz somebody has a
Lamborghini the [__] that got to do
with you ain't got nothing to do with
you as as if somebody else's joy and
flowers are taken out of your joy or
flowers I hate that [__] and you know
and you know what I believe in I always
believe in this and I tell people this
you got and this is what I believe 6 12
24 6 months 12 months 18 months 24
months I don't care who you are where
you at if you say if I say to myself you
know what I'm going to take this this sh
Sharpie right
here and I'm going to be the number one
seller of sharpies I'm going hold I'm
going to just sell Sharpies all I'm
going to do is sell
markers it's even going to be that six
that 12 that 18 and 24 that I'm going to
be popped and I'm going to be known as
the Sharpie man all over the world I'mma
do the I'mma document it I'mma do my
stuff whatever everybody sit back and
what I got what I call you got jumpers
out here oh I'm selling Sharie oh but
this dude selling merch that's popping
let me jump over there oh this dude do
oh that's let me jump over there oh let
me and what happened is that number what
happened when your blessing come arrive
like here I come I was waiting for you
you the [__] over there now here you go
you would have been a Sharpie man if you
would just stuck to this and said [__]
what everybody else is doing and just
said and think about it so many people
waste so much time in 24 months doing a
bunch of [__] and jumped all over the
place if they would have stayed with one
thing locked that in got the finances
and then you know you get brought Branch
out afterwards but nobody stay down you
know why why they're chasing paper yeah
that's the
problem the number one way to not have
paper is to chase it mhm real talk
because if you chase what you like and
or what you know you're good at
self-awareness of skill or
self-awareness of Joy somebody might
some people end up like me where you're
good at something and you love it right
mhm basketball just cuz I'm looking at
the Garden and it's over your shoulder
it blew me away in my late 30s when I
realized some athletes didn't give a
[__] about the sport I was like what I
was like cuz I love sports so much I was
like wait you don't love playing ball
and and the per you know these early
meetings I had when I started figuring
out they're like nah it was just my way
out and I was like damn right you're
good and then I was like oh that's why
some dudes are the most talented in the
world and don't [__] make it CU they
don't love it and when people put Kobe
or other people on a pedestal it's cuz
that man loved it more than anything of
course he when AI is like yo and then we
going to the club and Kobe's in the gym
I know why the same reason I was in the
office last night at 10 p.m. I'm not in
the office last night at 10 p.m. because
I need to make another dollar I'm in it
because I like this more than watching
Netflix or the game or chopping up or
getting drinks this is more fun for me
work and so when I think about the
reason so many people don't achieve what
you just broke down brilliantly is cuz
the sole reason they did crypto they did
cannabis they did sneakers they did
fashion I got a t-shirt brand I'm into
real estate now I'm an expert on this
now is they thought that this was going
to be the thing that got them the paper
instead of realizing either pick
something you
love you many people are a teacher they
love it more than life and they're not
going to get paid like that it's just
not the way the system works but what we
don't talk enough about is how many
human beings make 71,000 a year and are
happy we don't we don't talk about it
and it's real and they're like ah I hate
when people in comments like don't say
that [__] you're trying to hold me down
bro first of all I don't give a [__]
let's start with that I'm not trying to
hold you down or try to build you up I
can't control you I don't know
you I'm just saying things that I'm
observing I just know an obnoxious
amount of people who are wealthy as [__]
and miserable as [__] and I know
obnoxious amounts of people who do not
have a lot of money who are [__]
smiling 360 days a year yeah so can we
just have that combo yeah and and and I
believe this you make money changing the
game not following it yeah you got like
and when you real money listen real
money when you change the game when you
stick and say you know what oh nobody
doing this cuz I remember when I came
home from jail I'm doing videos Y and I
would get calls from people and I was
living in my grandma middle room right
I'm top the walls this thing I'm right
next to nny twin siiz bed same as in
prison what year is this uh 2017 I come
on February 18th 2017 I ra baby home for
7even years so listen I'm in there and I
never forget my grandma she just I know
she thought I was crazy cuz I used to be
in there laughing cuz I used to get
phone calls and people send me message
yeah what's her name was talking about
you they said you crazy running down the
street doing the videos and all that and
I'll be in there cracking up and NY like
I'm just I'm watching I'm laughing at
something Nanny and she didn't
understand I was laughing because I was
like yes I got these [__] ain't
nobody on what I'm on y'all think I'm
crazy y'all lost by the time y'all catch
up I'm going to be out of here I'm like
yes I got you everybody's Lo cuz
everybody wanted to be cool see let me
explain something to you I realize
something more than anything if I didn't
realize nothing is that for me growing
up a lot of people ain't see this movies
I'm looking at Steve I'm looking at I'm
looking at Bill I'm looking at all the
great people everybody that's making
some great stuff I'm looking at C I'm
looking at different people and I'm
saying oh y'all don't even understand
right now is Revenge of the Nerds is
over guys all that cool [__] you can't
monetize cool it's only momentarily it's
a feeling it's it's a moment it's a
party it's a song but it's not it's not
every day it's not going to be that
everyday thing because once you go to
the party once you go to the event once
you shoot the video once you get the
club the cool die right there now you
got to get to the work you got to get to
the real grind you got to get to the
real dedication and you got to be able
to execute in this world in order to win
all that other [__] and the think is Run
the World the people that's going to
think the people that's going to sit the
people that's going to create they're
going to win everybody else is going to
be sent back to oh I'm cool I'm partying
I was here okay you took a picture and
now the picture is over it's over you
did all that [__] to build up you said
let me go get these clothes let me go to
this club let me drink this liquor let
me take these pictures and then the next
morning you wake up
hammered and it was over it was all for
a picture and then you got people out
here that sitting back utilizing people
these illusionary Lifestyles and
utilizing them as measuring sticks on
social media say oh my life ain't
nothing that was a 1 second pcture dog
that might not even be his Lamborghini
like you you can just go anywhere and
rent cars you can rent cars the the
bigger question is why are you using
other people's lives as a validation
point to your own y like I'm telling
y'all right now we are putting youth on
a pedestal these young kids they know
technology better on some Nana [__]
let's just do it right here we have to
get back to respecting our elders yes on
some real talk we're [__] on people
because of Technology now that lived
life yeah like I can sense that we're
about to get back to it a little bit I
think if everybody spent a little less
time looking at 20-year-olds making
paper and spent a couple more hours with
their grandparents or the grandparents
friends even better if it's not your
family because it's not as loaded you
know people are just confused like again
the thought that you like blaming people
like I love when people are like it's
all the celebrities faults I'm like
don't watch them where's the [__]
accountability if you feel that you're
depressed because celebrities are
flexing on social media don't consume
social media and start and start
subscribing and start paying attention
to the people that's in our families the
elders in our communities that really
done it they won because I was talking
to my grandma and this is the classic
most thing she said to me her name is
Lois peoples nanny so nanny I'm talking
to Nanny she's 89 years old right love
nanny around nanny said can we get Nanny
on the podcast yeah I don't know man
Nanny don't like the camera she don't
like the digital stuff nanny can you
just be behind the scenes and just talk
I just want [__] Wisdom she going to
tell it I just want the [__] Wisdom L
I'm going to tell you this type of
wisdom I called her one time nanny
what's going on I said where you at she
said I'm downtown I said okay you
downtown said you drive what Nanny tied
New Balances up and she would jump on
the train and go downtown don't and
leave a car park so I say Nanny did you
drive I always ask he drive she said no
why I'm going drive before I caught the
train I'm so later on I I talked to her
I said damn man you got to you keep you
know being everywhere she said she said
she said she said said Wallace let me
tell you something if you stop moving
you stop moving baby he said all my
friends that stop moving he stop moving
she never stopped moving that was the
most powerful wisdom is I it was just
powerful I believe it because I never
looked at when I looked at the
neighborhood when I looked at I'm like
you're the oldest in your church you're
the oldest living member and around the
neighborhood you're the oldest living
living person in our whole Community
because nny always tired of sneaks up
and we'll go from here she f with New
Balances yeah yeah she she mess with she
she wear New Balance all type and she'll
just be out of here she be like she be
like oh right I'll be like where you at
Nanny oh I'm down what's name I'm at the
farmers market did you bring your car
nope I quau this and she just like she
just she keep moving so it's like you
said something that's very important we
got to start subscribing to the people
that already W in life she won already
she's a winner I know what every 21y old
influencer on social media is doing
they're playing high school they're just
trying to win clout y like by the way I
understand I think it's a piece of life
I understand how people do that but I
know what they're all doing and by the
way they can't help it they're 21 what
are we asking them for they're children
this what people get mad at all these
players like that kid [__] up like
that kid's 19 the [__] were you doing at
19 I love when all my boys talk sports
and our Sports thread like ah J [__]
up I'm like bro I know you at 19 I
[__] up at 19 you were way worse yeah
and you didn't have the world looking at
you or 250 million in the bank
[__] and you were more [__] up
shut your mouth the hypocrisy these kids
are children which goes back to the
point we're putting youth on a pedestal
everyone wants to be 20 I get it life is
like fun it's nice to be youthful I get
it but we've got it so you know
everything's best at balance we used to
disrespect kids when we came up the game
when you were 20 got two and got a new
job you got to get coffee you can't do
anything else you can't talk these 22
year olds walk into the company they
think they should be the vice president
day one I of the company I get it I know
know what's happening but that's on us
we've put Youth too and I [__] with
youth heavy yeah but we've lost our
balance we put him on a pedestal just
because they know how to use a [__]
iPhone and we completely I mean the
collective
disrespect that Society right now has
for 75 to 100 year olds without
understanding or acknowledging this deep
wisdom the Battle Scars of living life
the mistakes that they've learned from
the place where they actually don't give
a [__] anymore when you're
90 you're kind of not giving a [__] what
people think about your fit no you don't
care about you know what I mean and so I
just think we need to tap the [__] in
way more way more to wisdom and so when
I roll when I move when like when I'm in
life walking the street like especially
at the airport is where I historically
used to do it like just sitting down
next to somebody like I would literally
be like oh there's a seat next to a
90-year-old I'd sit down and like
remember because we disrespected the
elderly they're thrilled when you engage
they they they the best teacher yo you
know and like they they're thrilled and
they will engage and they will drop real
wisdom and I promise you the average 88y
old at the airport in 15 minutes will
give you more [__] than your stream will
give you all year why you don't why you
don't fly uh private jets I do sometimes
and I do more now you know I held off
because I never like the mistakes I make
is I'm to back to balance my
vulnerability is back to like not
wanting to be 2 minutes late I'm so
associate of where I came from that I
always viewed it as like I'm a sellout
that's
bougie you know like I hate when people
Flex those kind of things because I
don't think that brings value to people
on social like it just make like oh no
Gary it's inspiring them no it's not
it's making them feel shitty back to
your point like what are you
contributing taking a [__] selfie
like so I kind of demonized that the
reality is the last three or four years
my time has become so valuable yeah that
it's just good math for me now like it's
it's crazy to me that I'm in a place
where I can afford a flight like that
but if I don't and I do the commercial
thing I'm going to lose like what the
[__] am I who you know becomes this
thing where you start realizing if
you're going to preach all the [__]
you're preaching right here you got to
hold yourself accountable I'm like who
am I proving this [__] to I'm playing
this stupid game with myself of me
holding on of not like going there
meanwhile I'm just hurting myself
nobody's winning my body's not winning
my health mhm my like I'm not flexing it
anyway so nobody really I even felt
uncomfortable even jump I'm sad that you
just ask that because I don't even
really want to go there but it's just I
do now but I'll mix it up flight on
Friday to La commercial let me ask you a
question uh and and and this is a very
important question that people need to
know how old would you and do you
remember the moment where your [__] it
button came on where you didn't give a
[__] more I hate this question cuz it's
the right question question yeah but
again this is
where I I hate using me because I and I
hate using luck I said early why but
man [__] between the DNA I was gifted
when my Mom and Dad decided to have sex
that night in 1975 February on their
wedding night I was M I was born nine
months of the day of my parents wedding
night damn yeah my dad was 21 my dad my
mom was 20 that's what happens you know
back in the old country between the DNA
that I got from my parents which me and
my siblings always laugh that like I
took the best attributes from both of
them like I really got it like that
that's luck that wasn't me that was that
was them that moment between my mom the
way she parented me so it's not just you
know it's nature and nurture right it's
not only between the fact that I that
like my earliest memories are living in
Queens in a studio apartment the size of
this with eight family members but being
happy so I grew up with so little but I
was so happy I learned
by the time I was eight or nine that
happiness was not associated with
money and then by not grab that Tyler
report card top tiby top check this out
so I'm setting up your answer my guy
this is my report card from high school
wallo educate yeah bro it's speech a d
speech I'm one of the most highly paid
public speakers in the world you had a d
i got D in speech give it to W English
English a d German you got a f f Health
you got a d health you just have to show
up still got a d health you got a D but
physical education you got a a freshman
year what about sophomore
year you got a A of physical education
again and and junior year you got a A in
physical education and Senior year you
got a A in physical health you got a A
in health you came back got a in health
you got a be in film you got a be in
film I mean you got a a d and film
Concepts
I knew criminal justice you got to see I
cared about it reform Alliance what's up
yes yo check this out four years look at
my
GPA 1.67 look at my class rank 243 out
of
254 God damn my man when I tell you my
give no [__] button got pressed in
about fourth grade where I decided none
of the opinions of the girls that I
thought were cute and the guys that I
thought were cool nor my teachers nor my
report card had any indication on what
was I about and I have no [__] clue
how that happened because if I did i'
package it and sell it to everyone on
Earth because the last 40 years of my
life or 37 if we're going to be exact in
the timing have been very joyous CU I
tuned everyone
out everyone tune all the [__] out
of noise when you go through high school
and you act actually don't feel peer
pressure and I knew it was happening cuz
I felt it but when I got a little bit
older and understand life a little more
I'm like yo that mentality is crazy like
when the girl that you think is the
hottest the hottest is like hey you want
to hang out this Saturday and you're
like no I'm doing a baseball card show
like you're in a you're [__] like
you're weird yeah I was just in such a
weird place like big coming Monday
morning everyone's talking about the
biggest high school party I didn't even
know and I was popular like really cuz
I'm so like and I like people I knew I
was good like that but I was so like
this that I come in Monday morning be
like I didn't even know the party was
going down and I was friends with
everyone there and they probably told me
but I was like this Saturday at the
Phils mall I'm going to sell those
[__] Ken griffy junr rookie cards
that I popped off from the kid like I
was
so the only thing I ever gave a [__]
about was the market the world
I give so much [__] about what's going
on behind this camera right now but
equally I don't and that's the magic the
reason I can be a public figure I've
realized now why I keep moving is I
don't see when when I post something all
those goat emojies I don't believe
them I don't think I'm special I'm aware
of what I got not delusional I'm not
trying to but but all those goat emojis
and I get plenty of them thank God thank
you I don't believe them which sets me
up for when someone says yo [__] you I
don't believe them either the mistake
everyone's making right now in society
is you want the accolades you [__]
live for the accolades you eat those
accolades up mhm but when the [__]
booing comes you're broke because you
thought the cheering was right and I'm
just [__] calm I'm in the [__]
middle I'm wishing well for [__] all
of
y'all but I'm just on my [__] and I want
good for everyone else and when I see
somebody doing it bigger than me I'm
pumped when I saw you doing your thing
like I'm just happy for everyone cuz
everyone can eat MH the second I know
someone can't win is the second they
start telling me that someone else is
eating their
food damn I'm like you're
done you're telling me you can't be on
the top of the charts cuz Drake the [__]
are you talking about
M the [__] are you talking
music like then ice spice couldn't
happen because Meg the stallion happened
but me couldn't happen CU cardi happened
but wait Cy couldn't happen because
Nikki had like enough of this [__]
my friends once and for all you want to
be
happier start realizing that everything
that isn't working is on you ain't no
one taking your
[__] and the second you go there it's
game over now you're on like oh wait I
can do it because if you think LeBron is
[__] you up
then it's over you think he took your
spot you think no other black man can be
motivational the [__] are you talking
about y enough of this [__] there's
unlimited unlimited opportunity but
people aren't
accountable I always say if somebody in
the world has made it AKA happy and
successful that had your circumstances
your excus is void my mom is the
greatest Mom that ever lived I respect
that other people could tie her if you
feel that way about your mom's my mom
lost her mom at five grew up in the
Soviet
Union like the shittiest place on Earth
we couldn't leave the
country her dad then goes to jail for 10
years when she's
10 she figured it the [__]
out so like I don't know like people are
just always trying to explain to me why
not I'm just like the second you like my
favorite thing about life when people
are like the algorith social right the
algorithms are so negative I'm like cuz
you're negative come look at my
algorithm Jets football a cat being
saved out of a tree by a fireman my
shit's [__] beautiful because I'm not
willing to let negtive you find what
you're looking for in life if you're
hurt you're looking for bad [__] you're
just spending all your time cuz they're
trying to the world's trying to sell you
fear that's how they control you y you
get to decide in life I can go on the
internet right now and in 5 seconds show
you 50 things that are phenomenal I can
go to Google happy news enter news boom
boom boom boom or I could show you 50
things are ter about watching all of
y'all beat each other up trying to
convince each other to see the world
exactly how you see it because of the
way you grew up it's
exhausting no compassion no empathy no
capacity to understand why someone would
if you grew up in a deeply religious
home in the south I understand how you
might have different opinions about
religion and abort I get it the same way
that I grew up and went to Martin Luther
King Elementary School with a insane
amount of diversity so I see it
different we're allowed but right now
we're like no I'm right you're wrong and
we're just fighting and fighting and
fighting and fighting and negative and
negative and negative and like I'm just
in the cut trying to put out
positivity and being empathetic like I
can't control everybody's outcomes so
I'm just going to leave the posits of
good hopefully some people will take it
and
run just live life that's what I'm
talking about man Gary ve man we's
wallow man I appreciate you
[Music]
brother